الانتخابات التي شغلت تركيا والعالم حسمت
بتمديد عباءه الحكم للرئيس اردوغان لولايه
ثالثه وحتى عام 2028 وهي الاخيره له طبعا
بموجب الدستور التركي الذي يمنعه من
الترشح لولايه رابعه بالارقام مشاهدينا
نتعرف على نسبه مشاركه الناخبين الاتراك
في جوله الاعاده والتي بلغت نحو 84% فيما
كانت الجوله الاولى كما نشاهد هنا 89
بالمئه ومن هنا لابد ان نتوقف عند الارقام
التي نالها اردوغان في ابرز المدن وغير
شيئا منها بدايه فلنتوقف عند المحافظه
التي خسرها اردوغان في الجوله الاولى وعاد
وقلص الفارق فيها في الجوله الثانيه اتحدث
هنا عن هاتاي وهي ابرز المناطق المتضرره
في الزلزال حيث في الجوله الثانيه بلغت
نسبه التصويت 49.
بالمئه اما في الجوله الاولى فبلغت
48.3% اي تقدم بفارق حوالي 12 الف صوت عن
جوله الاقتراع الاولى اما مشاهدينا في
المدن الكبرى مثل اسطنبول التي وصفت بانها
ام المعارك الانتخابيه فتقدم اردوغان
بالجوله الثانيه عن الجوله الاولى كما
نشاهد هنا بالجوله الثانيه 48 فصل 22%
بالجوله الاولى
46.68
اي قلص الفارق باكثر من 20 الف صوت مع
منافسهم ننتقل الى العاصمه التركيه انقره
وثاني اكبر المدن التركيه ايضا قلص فيها
هنا اردوغان الفارق مع منافسه كريدي بعد
منال
48.77% في الجوله الثانيه وفي الجوله
الاولى
46% اي فارق اكثر من 100 الف صوت
وهذا يعني مزيد من الاصوات التي ساهمت
بفوز اردوغان في جوله الاعاده للانتخابات
التركيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات